did you watch the game last night yeah
yeah we're in double ot
we are in double overtime yeah man i i
was
we were just looking at the betting
markets the whole time i'm sure yeah
everyone was
dude even the uh cs go yeah
there were like there's a so you can buy
skins for guns
uh [ __ ] felix from choppo was
tweeting this
like it was retweeting people watching
the betting lines
for skins based on the election so
people were betting
oh yeah it was everywhere you could have
made wow
so all of you who are like i don't care
about voting and you could have made
money last night
stupid but you slept on it you decided
to play games or watch
you know the bachelorette or something
hold on the skins
were themed like not in blue no no you
could like bet skins
on because some of those skins on the
right right right i forgot you could
like gamble with
yeah csgo sounds so bad you could bet
skins on the election
but wait so they do they have someone
working for cs go setting the lines
no do you don't remember that whole
drama and how like
how sketch valve was for that whole
thing
so vaguely so they in they introduced
the idea of skins and then
bro they created an api for it okay like
so you could just
any third it was just came out of
nowhere any third party site
you say oh yeah you want to access skins
and so here's a little just a cool
little endpoint okay
do your thing okay and then so people
made third-party betting markets
yeah to like trade skins and stuff but
then somebody's setting the line or are
they just using
like a betting site api i know one
person i see i see what you're saying
so and for that i don't know i would
guess someone's setting the line yeah
you know we just make stuff up on this
show yeah so
someone said yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
dude name uh
chris story no crystal cory crystal yeah
no crystal corey that's this is gamer
name
and crystal corey yeah it was crystal
with a case crystal corey sounds like a
nice swimming
pond crystal you've been out of the
crystal of course it's a fortnight
location
crystal quarry baby yeah last night was
crazy and then it's
been crazy this morning too i mean i
went to bed thinking trump's gonna win
i mean he threw the he threw the red
flag he challenged the play right at
midnight what did he say
i didn't watch it did you watch his
speech yeah well first of all
him making all the anchors do material
until he wanted to get on stage is the
most
like headliner comic [ __ ] i've ever seen
yeah you know
i felt like i was doing a show at like
the haha cafe or something
you mean like was it on fox no he just
you know he's he's like it was like
trump is going to speak and he just
still wouldn't come out on stage
actually it's not really comedian [ __ ]
it's more like it's more like rappers
rapper yeah it's like coachella
headliner like everyone's
like and then every single and then like
a dude comes out on stage to test the
sound everyone's like
he's like no just just swear relax relax
yeah
and then you just hear the distant
chatter of 50 000 people
well that reminds me of when i went to
old festival rock the bells they have
every year they have a special guest and
one year i went
it was lauren hill okay and
uh the host was trying to
keep people engaged while lauren hill
i don't know what was going on maybe she
was late or whatever
but this dude was on stage burning the
clock
like doing comedy or whatever no just
just trying to keep people hyped
you know who wants some water let me get
a case of water
up here spread that around you know
all right dj play that and everyone you
know is
when's the one the [ __ ] is the special
guest
that's the the most thankless job yeah
it really is yeah
yeah and well so then when the funniest
part is like are y'all ready for your
special guest
y'all ready everybody make some noise
for lauren hill
half the crowd went um what
oh was it a surprise yeah it's supposed
to be a surprise
because the purpose of rock the best
sucks it was it was a wu-tang got
together every year
so everyone's like chris bring the woo
out here [ __ ] that [ __ ] it was like
super mean damn
so you know that i was waiting for it
you know for trump speaks and then like
he just sends out jared kushner
everyone's like ah get this full
up so yeah he came out at
midnight or some [ __ ] and he just you
know he starts
he's just starts saying you know we won
matt greatly
yeah greatly yeah strongly yeah yeah
we didn't just win it we won it but you
know you just start reading the numbers
and basically he's saying that
oh the you know democrats are they're
cheating because they're gonna find
you know magic votes uh
in the next few days they're gonna add
ballots and the whole thing is rigged
he said would i tell you newt like
looking at nougat what'd i tell you man
they're rigging it they're going to
cheat they're going to find these votes
and they're going to get me out of here
so you know he he challenged the play
basically and so he the the thing that
everyone was
going crazy over is he said he's gonna
go to the supreme court
stop the voting you know so
whatever but here's the thing now if he
loses
which it seems like he is no he's like
he's like
plus 350 or something like that binds
like minus 500.
um so you bite all your skins to trump
is what you're saying i'm throwing my
skin to trump no to to biden
biden biden is favored now but it's like
even if he if biden wins trump has now
like set this precedent of like oh he's
yeah no
it's like everyone's gonna think this is
like a fraudulent win and the next four
years are bunk and then he's going to
run again in 2024.
we're going to be back in this exact
same position in four years it's
insurance man that's all it is social
insurance
just get out of here yeah you know what
i'm saying like yeah
and that's not even i just don't i don't
i'm not a fan of him you know he's
like trump you should just go to
wrestling yeah
he's he's got he knows what [ __ ] drop
another
season of uh the apprentice that [ __ ]
would
bang dude
that [ __ ] dude that would be i watched
the [ __ ] out of that
i would be tweeting him every day you
down bad huh
yeah yeah yeah back on tv
dork how's it feel
uh you're back down here with everybody
else
you're just another dude yeah no more
president
how's it feel yeah that's what
he's going to be thankful that he's not
a president anymore because he can go
back to blocking people
yeah yeah yeah he's still he's he's
still doing that
blocking no he's been doing that twitter
doesn't let you or didn't let him they
unblocked
everything really you don't know that no
but he was doing it like at the
beginning oh yeah and then
twitter on like forcibly unblocked
everyone rightfully so yeah
the weirdest thing you can do as
president i think block your own people
just shut up i don't want to hear it i
don't want to hear it
no i think that's skewed you know back
in the day not anyone could just talk to
a president
you know yeah yeah that's true but
i mean yeah it's different now you could
write into the social dilemma dog
ever heard of that that's the thing the
social dilemma season two
yeah we made trump depressed
it's our responsibility that he's yeah
he's hateful because trump's like the
out the algorithm
the algorithm
what if trump blames the loss on the
algorithm yeah it just starts trashing
youtube
do you know twitter wasn't showing my
posts anymore to people
and so less people knew strongly that we
were
greatly in the lead do you know how much
money
i spent do you know how much money i put
into youtube
and all my videos less than 500 000
views and demonetize every one of them
it's rigged for being strongly and
greatly political
but but but but then but cnn they take
my videos and they talk about it they're
not demonetized
so why am i being demonetized
i think he has to like swing his arms
like that because his mouth is so small
cause you gotta get the
he's got the butthole mouth he does yeah
yeah
that [ __ ] creeps me out yeah whenever
people got the butthole mouth
it's really only him who else talks like
this
he talks in a no he talks like he's
blown smoke rings no you i've definitely
encountered
the butthole mouth yeah yeah the
butthole mouth is
is it it you know it's out there
it's not there now it's out there yeah
it's out there